Der Titzler langweilt sich, das Wetter ist ermild, aus seiner Laune ersteigert sich Stefan ein Bild. Im Auto geht's zum Auktionshaus nach Düsseldorf. Endlich darf Tingo das Bild in echt bestand.
Doch was ist hier denn los, oh mein Gott, Fanta kriegt einen Schock.
Was macht er jetzt, Blu-Gus, denn das Bild ist viel zu gross, zu groß. Das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Thiese-Thiese und Florentin Wölf. Hi, fantastisch. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit mir, das bin ich, und mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan Thiese, wie immer. Er ist dabei, schön, dass du da bist. Ich freue mich auch sehr, dass ich hier sein darf, immer noch.
Wie sehr freust du dich, dass endlich dein Leben als Musical umgeschrieben wird, endlich wird dein Leben in Musik gefasst.
Ich denke die ganze Zeit nur Gemma, Gemma, Gemma, Angst, Angst, Angst, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, aber danach, ich denke auch stolz und wie cool, dass Leute meinen Namen reimen und dass mittlerweile auch so viele Spitznamen aufgetaucht sind, Tingo, Titzler, Fanta, dass auch irgendwann alle Wörter darauf reimbar sind. Und das steigert natürlich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen die Motivation, darüber mal einen Song zu machen. Stimmt, es ist eigentlich ein guter Plan, sich immer Spitznamen zu geben, auf denen man gut reimen kann, in der Hoffnung, dass ein Leben irgendwann... Ja, in einem speziellen Interesse, dass Leute über einen Songs machen. Irgendwann mein Leben in ein Limerick gefasst wird, sodass man das gut darstellen kann.
Aber du bist der Herr der Dateien und weißt dementsprechend, wie der Komponist hieß.
Absolut. Das ist Queen mit Simons Interpretation und vielen, vielen Dank dafür.
Simon, vielen Dank, mega, das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Wir haben uns grüsselig gelacht.
Ja, und schön auch wieder Fiepsi die Maus am Ende nochmal zu sehen. Die wurde irgendwann eingeführt in dem Intro und ist seitdem treuer Begleiter dieses Podcasts, unser kleines Maskottchen, das sich sehr, sehr schlecht verkauft, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Sämtlicher Fiepsi-Merch liegt staubig in Berlin herum, füllt die Warenhäuser und ich will nicht sagen, dass die Brandgefahr enorm ist, aber jeder Tag ist ein Roulette-Spiel, sag ich mal. Ein Ritt auf dem Vulkan, ein Tanz auf dem Vulkan. Vielleicht weil wir diese Disco darüber nicht eröffnen hätten sollen, aber gut. Aber ich fand es gut gerade, das kennt man ja auch häufig mittlerweile aus Zügen oder generell öffentlichen Plätzen, immer dieses wütend den Laptop anschreien, wo ist denn der Ton, wo ist denn der Ton, auf die Lautsprechertasten hauen und dann plötzlich ganz leise werden und dann so beschämend zum Rucksack gehen, weil man dann gehört hat, dass der Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer im Rucksack Werbung tönt und ordentlich Sounds macht, weil natürlich die Kopfhörer, die Blutkörfer sich dazwischenschalten einfach. Ja, ganz furchtbar. Das ist eine ganz furchtbare Hexentechnologie, die sich irgendwie immer dazwischenschaltet.
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich den umgekehrten Fall mal erlebt, weil ich habe mich dazu aufgeschwungen, mal mich in den neuen Medien herumzutollen.
Und ich habe eine Sprachnachricht aufgezeichnet, ich habe jemandem eine Sprachnachricht geschickt.
Du hast eine Sprachnachricht komponiert.
Ich habe sie komponiert, genau, verfasst, die Partitur vor mir, und dachte mir, okay, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht und eins. Und habe angefangen und habe diese Sprachnachricht aufgenommen. Und ja, da waren ein paar solide Gags mit drin, Wortspiele, Reime ... Und etwas zu viel Übung, oder? Man merkt, du hast es nicht zum ersten Mal gesprochen. Ich denke, bei allen Sprach, die ich spreche, weil ich die ja probe und probe und probe tagelang, man hört das halt noch irgendwie raus. Man hört, dass ich diese ganzen Sätze nicht zum ersten Mal sage.
Das allerschwierigste bei einer Sprachnachricht ist das erste Wort.
Hi!
Ach, nochmal, das klang viel zu aufgesetzt, viel zu künstlich.
Na, das klang jetzt wieder viel zu vorbereitet.
Hi!
Also wirklich dieses Hi!
Ah, das war jetzt wieder zu ernst.
Ich mach wirklich, also wenn man sich anguckt, der Graph der Wiederholung der Sprachnachricht, die erste Sekunde enorm hoch, danach scheißegal. Danach husten, stolpern, Handy fällt aus, da sind die Treppe runter, bleibt alles drin, aber der Anfang muss sitzen. Hi, hi, weil das vermittelt ja schon eigentlich alles. Wie es losgeht, wird die gesamte Sprachnachricht eigentlich wahrgenommen. Und wichtig ist auch immer der Satz, hi, ich mache das mal als Sprachnachricht, weil das jetzt sonst zu lang. Sowas, weil das ist also das Entschuldigende. Auch nicht zu viel Anlauf, kein hi, das Einatmen am Anfang, das ist ein ganz klassischer Anfängerfehler, nicht das Einatmen am Anfang mit reinnehmen, sondern... Gerne abschneiden, gerne anfangen, dass man hart reingeht, ei, was auch nicht so schlecht ist, das Hai darf auf gar keinen Fall vermitteln, dass die Sprache nach je zwölf Minuten lang ist. Nee, dieses, nein, Hai, so. Ja genau, nicht dieses, wir müssen reden, Hai, sondern dieses, äh, Hai, nur ganz kurz, äh, Hai, äh, Hai ist auch nicht schlecht, äh, Hai, ich mach's kurz hier, äh, so, als wäre man reingestolpert ins Gespräch. Als wäre plötzlich die Sprachnachrichtfunktion aufgegangen und man müsste jetzt kurz, ah, hi, du, ich nutze das jetzt hier mal ganz kurz, hi, und ganz kurz, um das zu Ende zu führen, ich habe die Sprachnachricht aufgenommen, ja, ein Wunderwerk, eine Sinfonie der Sprache und abgeschickt.
Und dann kam natürlich die obligatorische, du, ich verstehe fast gar nichts Antwort. Finger auf den Mikrofon. Und tatsächlich, bei mir war es genau andersrum, Bluetooth-Kopfhörer war verbunden, Mikrofon des Bluetooth-Kopfhörers. Im anderen Raum hat die Sprachnachricht aufgenommen, was zu einem ... Ab und zu der Kühlschrank so ... ... geführt hat, wo die Person wahrscheinlich mit ganz zu schlitzen, zugekniffenen Augen auf der anderen Seite saß und wirklich den Lautsprecher in die Ohrmuschel hineingeschoben hat und wirklich sich bemüht hat, gib mir was, konsolant, ein Lokal. Das ist ne Teufelstechnologie, weil Bluetooth immer Priorität ist, nicht, dass nur mich fragt, möchtest du das verbinden? Nein, Bluetooth ist immer so, ja, bla bla bla, am Start, hier am Start. Ist immer so der Freund, der immer dabei ist, den man nicht rausbekommt aus dem Freundeskreis, der ist einfach jetzt da. Was ich auch oft habe, ich liege mit meinem Bluetooth-Kopfhörer im Bett, will noch schön irgendwie ein bisschen Katy Perry hören zum Einschlafen und hab mein mein iPhone direkt neben dem Kopfhörer und mein iPhone connecting to MacBook. Das MacBook liegt im anderen Raum, ist zu, schläft schon seit einer Stunde, ist durch, Tag beendet. Aber ist groggy auch, weil der Tag war anstrengend. Und diese scheiß unhöflichen Kopfhörer rütteln an diesem Laptop, hallo, hallo, ich will verbinden, während das iPhone bereit daneben steht und sagt, hi, ich würde gerne jetzt einmal die Verbindung. Wachen Augen, aufgeregt schon ein bisschen. Jetzt ist meine Schicht, jetzt bin ich dran und dieser Scheiß Kopfhörer rüttelt am MacBook ohne das iPhone zu beachten. Aber da muss man auch sagen, die Bluetooth-Technologie ist auch sehr immer monoperspektivisch. Es ist nicht immer, dass man da mal rechts und links Augen für andere Geräte hat. Monogam wenn, muss man sagen, Bluetooth ist so monogam, wenn dich fokussiert auf ein Gerät. Da rechts und links ist nichts daneben. Eigentlich schön, weil so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt man im echten Leben gar nicht mehr. Monogam, aber hängt auch sehr dem Ex-Freund hinterher, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Also immer wieder auf dieses scheiß alte iPhone, das ich seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr benutze, immer noch so connecting to iPhone 4 und man schreit, es ist vorbei. Es ist vorbei, das war es. Hach auf da nochmal zu verbinden. Das war für uns beide nicht gut, das war keine gute Beziehung, das hat gute Gründe, warum es vorbei ist, es hat sich auseinandergelebt, definitiv. Es hat jetzt einen anderen Kopfhörer, okay, du vergisst es, du kommst nicht mehr rein, Bluetooth ist einseitig. Es ist ganz furchtbar. Das trifft so ganz gut. Bluetooth ist sehr monogam, hängt aber extrem extra hinterher. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe neulich mal plötzlich, habe ich mich wiedergefunden, kennt man ja, bei Instagram plötzlich in so einer, es war damals so einer Impf, mit einem Impfgegner habe ich mich wiedergefunden, ja, weil es war dann plötzlich ... Das Klassische, gegen wen kämpfe ich heute? Ja, genau. An wen verliere ich heute meinen Verstand? Jemand, so ein Kumpel bei Instagram, der plötzlich sowas gepostet hat wie, ich stelle ja oft Fragen, ich will ja nur mal Fragen stellen, muss das sein mit der Impfpflicht, bla bla bla bla. Antwort ja. Antwort ja, dann habe ich ihm geschrieben, dann kam eine Sprachnachricht zurück, dann kam nicht nur die eine, sondern zwei und drei zurück und dann habe ich mich bewogen gefühlt, auch Sprachaufnahmen aufzunehmen. Bei Instagram wusste ich nicht genau, wie es läuft, neues Territorium der Sprachnachricht für mich. Ich dachte, willkommen, authentisch rein, drückt drauf und ich schicke ab, was kommt, ich schicke ab, was kommt, wie im Gespräch, nimm es, wie im Gespräch war. Hab es dann auf die Taste gedrückt, hab dann schön reingesprochen und dann war ich fertig mit meinem Monolog, hab das Handy weggenommen und sehe, ja, nach einer Minute bricht es automatisch ab und schickt es halt los. Oh. So, heisst es, meine erste Minute von meinem fünf Minuten Monolog war schon im Äther und der Rest nicht. Das Schöne daran war aber, weil es authentisch war, weil es zum ersten Mal gesagt wurde. So, und dann kommt man in so eine Übungsspirale rein, weil jetzt nimmt man es nochmal auf, die letzten vier Minuten, halt für jede Minute so für sich und merkt dann, ach, das habe ich alles schon mal gesagt. Die Zahlen stimmen nicht. Die Zahlen stimmen doch nicht. Jetzt wenn ich es nochmal lese, verstehe ich es nicht mehr.
Irgendwann war ich dann bei, ja, du hast schon recht, dass man das mal in Frage stellt. Das ist nicht so einfach, ehrlich gesagt, das dann so authentisch hinzubekommen. Weil man merkt dann doch, dass man, wenn man Dinge schon mal gesagt hat, häufig dazu neigt, Dinge weird auszusprechen oder so. Absolut, und was ich auch schon mal hatte, war Sprachnachricht, sofort danach eine Antwortsprachnachricht, sofort danach wieder eine Sprachnachricht von mir, dann wieder von dem anderen, wo ich dann geschrieben habe, wollen wir telefonieren? Und dann kam wieder eine Sprachnachricht, und dann ging doch die Sprachnachricht, weil ich mir dachte, das ist jetzt halt wirklich, ich meine, wir können das jetzt so fortführen, aber wir führen gerade ein telefonisches Gespräch mit Hürden. Nee, es ist schlimmer. Nein, nein, es ist schlimmer. Oft verstehe ich die Datensberechtigung von Sprachnachrichten, aber manchmal ist es auch einfach so, man könnte auch einfach telefonieren und das einfach kurz klären, anstatt immer ewig zu warten. Ich will der Person ins Wort fallen. Ich habe ja schon nach 20 Sekunden verstanden, was die Person sagen will. Und dann sagen wir, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, aber jetzt lass mich noch mal das sagen, was ich gerade schon mal gesagt habe. Das würde ich gerne noch mal sagen, in leicht anderen Worten. Richtig, genau. Und Sprachnachrichten verhindern das so ein bisschen. Ich finde, Sprachnachrichten sind doch was anderes, auch wenn du jetzt die Hin und Her im Dialog hin und her schickst, weil du halt einfach das Gegenüber zwingst, zuzuhören bis zum Ende. Ja.
Und du musst es ausklingen lassen.
Du könntest ja hinten in den letzten zehn Sekunden noch irgendwie ein gutes Argument verstecken.
Ja, ich hatte die Idee, also WhatsApp, falls sie zuhören, Idee fürs neue Update, bei jeder Sprachnachricht ein kleiner Button daneben, vielleicht ein A oder so,
und da kann man drauf tippen und WhatsApp wandelt automatisch die Sprachnachricht in Text um und gibt dir den Text nochmal drunter. Das kannst du einfach machen, aufs Mikrofon klicken und auf der Tastatur. Nee, andersrum. Ich will die Sprachnachricht, die der andere mir geschickt hat, will ich umgewandelt haben in Text. Die willst du als Text bekommen. Durch Spracherkennung. Mit allen S und Öms und Is. Ja, S kannst du rausnehmen oder sowas. Aber einfach, falls du in einer Situation bist, wo du jetzt gerade keinen Nerv hast oder irgendwie den Text nochmal sehen willst oder jeder kennt es, eine achtzehnminütige Sprachnachricht, wo irgendwer bei Minute sechseinhalb irgendwie, ja, wir treffen uns um achtzehn Uhr und dann denkst du dir, wann treffen wir uns, muss ich jetzt die ganze Dreckspacken Nachrichten nochmal? Da hätte ich gerne einen Button für die wichtigsten Punkte. Sowas, eine Zusammenfassung. Ja genau, das ist eine kleine Gl Glühlampe, da kann man klicken, dann geht die an, oder auch nicht, ist auch egal, vielleicht ist es einfach nur so ein haptisches Pressding, ich hänge mich da zusammen dran. Nee, kommt, ist ja auch eine Designentscheidung, das hängt ja nicht nur an der Idee, sondern muss ja auch insgesamt. Ja, Glühlampe ist solche dann jedenfalls, dann gibt die einem so die wichtigsten Punkte der Sprachnachricht. Ja. Oder halt. Absolut, ich glaube der Schritt ist erst mal dieses grosse A, dieses mit Serifen. Wie gross soll das sein? Naja, es ist halt Liberation Sons, schön ein grosses A, Kursiv. Na, vielleicht mit Serifen, ja Kursiv. Mit Serifen, Kursiv? Immer mit Serifen, Kursiv. Kurserifen, immer mit dabei. Dann tippst du drauf, dann hast du so einen kleinen, dann kann dieses A, vielleicht hat er so einen Arm, wo es sich so am Kinn greift, zu kurz nachdenken. Nein, nein, nein. Na ja, du brauchst, na klar, was Kleines. Oder so am Kopfkasten. Einfuss Termin, sorry. Halt sie für Ladezeit, sorry, bleib mal kurz da, setz dich noch mal hin. Also um die Ladezeit zu erbrücken, dass das A so ein bisschen grübelt und dann Kinn, Kratzen, Kopf, Kinn, Kinn, Kriben, Kopf, Kratzen. Herr Will, die Funktion ist ganz, ganz toll. Das Problem ist nur, sie hängen so stur an ihrer Designidee. Nein, nein, nein, weil die User, lass uns kurz über die Usability reden. Haben wir schon achtmal. Du hast halt so Kinnreiben, Kopfkratzen. Kinnreiben, Kopfkratzen. Du kannst dir so eine Art Zufallsmechanismus einbauen, welche von beiden Gesten kommt, das natürlicher ist. Und dann, wenn das vorbei ist, dieses kleine Stück, dieses Kinn-Schläfenspiel, Reiben hin und her, Wenn das sich dann langsam, aber sicher dem Ende neigt, dann erscheint nach jähem Hin und her endlich der Text, der Sprachnachricht in Textform, komplett kursiv, fett. und dann kann der User das lesen und dann kann man es aber auch so einklappen, also du hast unten dann auch so ein kleines Fähnchen, so ein kleines Fähnchen, dass du dann auch da drauf tippen kannst, dass es dann wieder so eingeklappt wird, dass es dir nicht den kompletten Verlauf zuspammt, sondern dass es dann mit so einem kleinen, wie wenn du sowas aufrollst. Wie ein Widget. Genau, wie ein Widget, ja genau, Dass du es dann wieder zu einklappst. Wie viele Ideen, glaubst du, wurden nicht umgesetzt, weil der Entwickler an zu vielen Details hing. Wahrscheinlich. So an Entweder so Design-Ideen oder so nebenbei. Aber das soll nur dafür eingesetzt werden. Oh, nee, Atombombe nicht. Lieber nur für Energiegewinnung. Wie viele gute Ideen, glaubst du, wurden nicht umgesetzt? Wahnsinnig viele. Wahrscheinlich, weil so ein Detail dann auch einfach nicht klappt. Du hast dann so ein Prozent des Projekts, du kriegst halt nicht beide Buchstaben in den Raum rein. Das ist halt zu klein. Und dann denkt man sich, dann lassen wir es. Wenn ich den Button, den Hilfe-Button nicht genau so mache, wie ich ihn will, dann lassen wir alles, dann stampfen wir alles ein. Wir haben ja selber schon einige Projekte eingestampft, einfach weil wir, wir sind ja Perfektionisten, wir wollen dann auch den letzten Schliff richtig haben. Was ist das? Was ist das, Stefan? Mein Kaffeebecher. Das ist ein Kaffeebecher. Ja, nur der heiß bleibt. Warum ist der so gross? Der Deckel liegt da, da ist ein wenig Kaffee drin. Aber auch nicht so viel, nur über fünf Liter. Das ist wirklich so ein Mittelding zwischen Thermoskanne, Deckel und Thermoskanne. In der Grössenordnung bewegen wir uns. Du hast es gerade so ganz aus dem Nichts hergeholt. Ich trinke da schon bestimmt die ganze Folge raus, dass es jetzt erst auffällt.
Wahnsinn.
Ich will dir später eine Sprachnachricht.
Das ist ein Becher.
Ja, das ist ein Becher, das ist ein Thermosbecher, genau.
Das ist wirklich ein Thermosbecher, das ist fast ein Kelch.
Der Becker liegt da hinten, guck mal.
Das ist ein Kelch.
Das ist ein großer Thermosbecher und ich habe mir, weil es hier keinen guten Kaffee gibt,
einfach zu Hause noch schnell einen Kaffee gebrüht.
Auch ein tolles Wort, brühen. Ich finde das so, aufbrühen, finde ich so schön, da kriegt man direkt Lust darauf. Ich habe zu Hause einen schönen Kaffee aufgebrüht und habe mir den mitgebracht jetzt. Brühen ist aber nicht dasselbe wie braun, ne? Nee, braun ist quasi neu erschaffen und brühen ist mehr so instant-mäßig. Okay, gut. Gut, dass wir das auch mal geklärt haben. Jetzt nimmt er einen tiefen Schluck. Und mundet es? Mundet fantastisch. Aber dieser metallende Geschmack, dieser, der doch, der alles durchdringt ein bisschen, ist nicht so schön. Nee, aber ich finde es super, das hält alles warm, die ganze Kaffe, die ganze Kaffe, den ganzen Tag. Und ich weiß nicht, warum du das jetzt super lachen musst, dass ich in Thermos, in Thermoskanne ja dann doch. Naja, weil du mitten im Gespräch, während wir uns in die Augen geschaut hast, diesen riesigen schwarzen Kolben aus dem Nichts geholt hast, einfach so wirklich dieses Obsidian-Gewülz da einfach hochgeholt hast. Ich finde es abstrus, muss ich ganz ehrlich mal sagen. Wo du gerade Obsidian sagst,, warum sind Edelsteine kein Thema mehr in meinem Leben? War es mal? Ja, klar, aber diese Edelsteinsammlung kennt man doch aus jedem Kinderzimmer seiner Freunde damals. Ja, absolut. Jeder hat eine Edelsteinsammlung. Ja. Ich war ein großer Fan von Rubin und ich hatte auch so ein Glas Schl so zwei Rubinen irgendwie als Verzierung. Ein Glasschloss? Ein Glasschloss, also Schloss im Sinne von Märchenschloss. Ja, das habe ich nicht in Frage gestellt. Nicht wie vorher geschloss und das war sehr spitz. Also das war wirklich so ein Schloss mit so zwei Türmen, so ein bisschen wie das Disney-Schloss tatsächlich, nur mit zwei größeren Türmen links und rechts. Die waren extrem spitz, aus Glas sehr, sehr spitz, also wirklich massive Verletzungen zu fahren. Es ist angekommen, dass sie spitz waren. Mit zwei Rubinen. Wo waren die Rubine? Die waren vorne an den, also da, wo vielleicht bei einem Kirchturm die Uhr wäre, waren da zwei kleine Rubine eingesetzt. Wahrscheinlich nicht echt. Was ist das für ein Geschenk? Das habe ich tatsächlich mal einem Mädchen aus meiner Klasse geschenkt, das ich mochte. Das war ein Riesen-Eklat. Das war ein Riesen-Eklat, weil das mir wieder zurückgegeben wurde. Wurde so eine Klassensitzung einberufen? Wurde wegen dem eine Klassensitzung einberufen? Nein, es war richtig unangenehm. weil es wurde zurückgegeben wurde. Wurde so eine Klassensitzung einberufen? Wurde jemand eine Klassensitzung einberufen? Nein, nein, nein, es war richtig unangenehm, weil es wurde zurückgegeben und meine Mutter meinte, das ist viel zu wertvoll, das kannst du nicht einfach irgendeinem Mädchen aus deiner Klasse schenken. Irgendeinem dahergelaufenen Flittchen aus deiner Klasse. Und das war wirklich irgendwie klar, weil ich in meiner Hilflosigkeit mit dem anderen Geschle umzugehen, einfach auf Geschenke umgestiegen bin und einfach Sachen hergeschenkt habe, die mir, glaube ich, auch nicht so wirklich besessen haben sind.
Oh Gott.
Und man merkt, dass ich ein grosses Jahr meiner Schulzeit damit verbracht habe,
die Geschenke präsente zu offerieren.
Und ja, das würde zurückgegeben in einer sehr peinlichen Situation, wenn man halt ein Mädchen mag, man schenkt ihr was und das gibt die einem dann wieder zurück im Sinne von, das hättest du mir nicht schenken dürfen. Aber das ist meine Geschichte zu Rubinen. Also daher kam, das war vielleicht auch der Moment in meinem Leben, wo ich dachte, vielleicht brauche ich non-materielle Dinge, mit denen ich mein Leben bestreite und lasse die Rubine hinter mir, dieses gepresste Graphit oder was ist das, gepresster Kohlenstoff. Du meinst Rubinen. Die da hinter mir her. Du meinst Diamanten. Amden? Diamanten meinst du. Diamanten, ja genau. Mantin. Diamanten. Aber Moment mal, ist ein Rubin was komplett anderes als ein Diamant oder ist es ein Diamant mit so einem Hauchkirsch drin? Null. Null Kirsch. Nee, Quatsch. Null Kirsch, null Diamant. Guck mal, Wasser und Apfelsaft sind nahezu ident Ja. Chemisch betrachtet. Aber ein Diamant und ein Rubin sind komplett anders. Was ganz anderes. Nein. Das eine ist Stein, das andere ist gepresster Kohlenstoff. Hör auf jetzt, ein Rubin ist ein Diamant mit ein bisschen ... Du sagst vor allem Diamant falsch, da fängt es bei mir schon an. Mit ein bisschen Himbeer drin. Ich würde ja auch gerne diskutieren jetzt lieber oder so, aber stattdessen dachte man die ganze Zeit nur böse, böse Themen weit beiseite wischen, weil du Diamanten sagst. Aber jetzt so ein Lapislazuli ist wieder was komplett anderes. Oh, das hätte ich auch noch gewusst. Ich hatte einen grossen Tourmalin, der war mein schönster Edelstein. Du kannst aber niemanden begeistern mit einer Edelsteinsammlung. Nein, nein. Jeder hat einen Lapislazuli, jeder hat einen Tomalin, jeder hat einen Bernstein, kein Schönerstein. Nein, nee, kannst du nicht? Jeder hat diesen Alpenquarz. Dieser Brocken, wo der Edelstein innen drin ist. Ach so. Wie heißt das mit diesen lila Dingen? Brocken, jeder hat auch diese grossen Quarz, diese orangenen. Was das Dümmste ist, weil je größer die Sachen sind, desto wertloser erscheinen. Wertloser Scheiss. Ja, was du willst ist, lass dir mal meinen Rubin zeigen und du willst irgendwie so eine winzig kleine Schatulle rausholen mit einer riesigen Lupe davor. Dann holst du aus einer zweiten Schatulle eine Pinzette raus, mit der du wiederum eine etwas kleinere Pinzette greifst. Und daneben sind so Einweghandschuhe, die du so dispensen kannst und dann kriegst du das eben. Und mit den
Handschuhen nimmst du eine kleinere Hand,
die eine etwas kleinere Pinzette nimmt,
die in die ganz kleine Schatulle reingreift
und da ein Staubkorn
großes, oranges... Uran
241 rausholt. Genau, und dann
hältst du es vor die
Lupe,
da erscheint es etwas grösser, nahezu nicht erkennbar, und dann sagt jemand, wow. Nicht wenn du sagst, hier so ein Brocken, halt mal, halt mal so einen fußballgrossen Brocken. Ja, das ist ein Kieselstein, genau so wertlos wie ein Kieselstein. Lächerlich. Was ihr wollt, Kinder, da draußen, ist, also verkauft eure Edelsteinsammlung oder schafft euch sie erst gar nicht an, Spart dasart das Geld, was euch eure Eltern Weihnachts mal geben für einen Edelstein, das werdet ihr bereuen. Klar, die Augen werden gross, die Farben sind toll, aber spart das ganze Geld und kauft einen Diamanten. So. Wo soll ein achtjähriges Kind ein Diamant her? Ja, wo kriegt das Labislazu-Läh her? Das ist ja auch genauso weird. Frag mal, zeig mir mal die Steine, die du hier nicht liegen hast, lieber Händler am Weihnachtsmarkt. Zeig mir die Steine, das müsst ihr fragen, genau so. Zeig mir mal, dann hältst du so einen 200-Euro-Schein hin und sagst, zeig mir mal die Steine, die hier nicht vorne liegen. Zeig mir mal die, die du da hinten hast. Sollte man generell fragen, auch bei McDonalds so, jetzt vergessen wir mal die Speisekarte, was haben sie denn so unter der Theke?
Egal wo man ist.
Obwohl da so einen alten Big Mac hervor, da so liegen geblieben ist. Aber generell immer eine gute Frage, ja. Und dann fokussiert dich auf einen teuren Stein und zeigt dir, tolles Geschenk vielleicht da draußen, falls du gerade ein Geschenk sucht für jemanden, der wissenschaftlich interessiert ist, man kann jetzt ein Periodensystem kaufen, wo jedes, jeder Element da drin ist, haptisch. Radioaktiv halt, muss man auch dazu sagen. Manche Sachen sind radioaktiv. Ja, ist sehr gefährlich, aber ist auch ein schönes Geschenk vielleicht. Diamanten sind eh strange, das ist ja so eine ganz merkwürdige Ökonomie mit Diamanten, weil du kannst Diamanten ja auch im Labor herstellen, das wollen aber viele nicht und niemand kauft gebrauchte Diamanten, obwohl das eigentlich unnötig ist, weil du brauchst einen Diamant ja nur für deinen Verlobungsring und wenn du stirbst, dann ist ja wieder ein Diamant frei. Dann könnte man einfach gebraucht kaufen für ein Drittel, will man aber nicht. Wieso Organspende soll das dann eigentlich werden? Man kann sich Interesse anmelden, dann stirbt jemandbt jemand und dann kriegt man den, wenn man jemanden wie oben auf der Liste steht. Ja, aber ja, gibt es von, ich glaube, 99% Invisible, gibt es dann auch einen tollen Podcast darüber, dass es irgendwie ein genialer Marketingstreich war, diesen Diamant als Verlobungsring so einzuführen und dass der so eine gewisse Anzahl an Monatsgehältern kosten soll. Ich glaube, drei Monatsgehälter soll ein Verlobungsring kosten. Was natürlich genial ist, weil für jeden es natürlich ähnlich viel wert ist. Aber dadurch, dass man dann denkt, allein dass die Regel in der Welt ist, dadurch hast du ein schlechtes Gewissen, dass wenn du dann weniger bezahlst. Tolle Regel, ja, ist eine gute Regel. Also ich habe mich auch eine, ich habe das mal gehabt, ich habe auch mal ein viel zu teures Geschenk geschenkt. Ja. Das war auch sehr peinlich. Wie alt warst du? Das war nicht lange her. Also das war vielleicht so im letzten Jahr, als es passiert. Und es kam zu Dates. Es kam zu einem ersten schönen Date, dann kam es zu einem zweiten schönen Date und irgendwann war dann schon so klar, ah okay, die Wege trennen sich so leicht, das war erst mal das letzte Date, weil dann ist sie umgezogen, aber ich dachte mir, okay, um jetzt den nächsten Schritt zu gehen, muss jetzt irgendwas, weil man kann sich natürlich auch weiterhin sehen und so und es war auch on the table. Und dann habe ich mich noch ans erste Date erinnert und ich hatte die beste Geschenkidee aller Zeiten für dieses letzte Date erstmal und aus dem ersten Date, wo sie gesagt hat, dass sie Parfum braucht, weil sie hat so eine ganz, so eine coole Geschichte über ihr Parfum, was sie irgendwie geschenkt bekommen hat mal irgendwann und was jetzt leer wird und was sie schon immer hatte, aber nicht weiß, weil man es findet nicht heraus, wo man es kaufen kann und so weiter.
Super.
Und dann habe ich irgendwann mal ... Und dann fing es an, dass sie Lawine in so einen ringen, weil dann habe ich sie gefragt, weil ich wusste nicht, ich wollte ihr das schenken dann, das Parfum, ich dachte mir, das findest du raus, bringst du das mit, mega.
So, habe sie gefragt, weil ich kam natürlich nicht anders dran, als sie zu fragen, schick mir mal ein Bild von deinem Flacon, so. Konntest du sie nicht einfach riechen? Ja, und dann konntest du nicht einfach mit einem ausgebildeten Parfümeur sie besuchen und an die Thomas aus Neuwied, der bei Betten das mitgemacht hat, den habe ich ausfindig gemacht, habe den mitgeschläust, an den Nebentisch drappiert.
Oder so bei Douglas, kann ich Ihnen helfen? Ja, gut, dass Sie fragen können, Sie tatsächlich. Kommen Sie mal ganz kurz mit, ich stelle Ihnen mal eine junge Frau vor, riechen Sie die mal. Ja, so, also musste ich sie fragen. Wo ich schon dachte, ah egal, sie wird schon checken, dass ich jetzt das schenke. Wir haben auch schon über was gesprochen, dass man sich was schenkt. Also es war alles einigermaßen offen, weil es einigermaßen klar war, dass es so das letzte Date erstmal war.
So, dann dachte ich mir, ja, sie weiss es ja jetzt, hat mir das Bild geschickt, ich habe es sogar herausgefunden schon, wo man das kaufen kann.
Und es war alles relativ kurzfristig, weil das nächste Date stand bevor. Dann hat sie gesagt, on an unrelated note, hast du noch einen Plattenspieler? Und ich so, ja. Und dann dachte mir, aha, jetzt schenkt sie mir ja auf jeden Fall was, vielleicht eine Platte. Ja. Okay, gut, jetzt brauche ich ja auf jeden Fall was. Wahrscheinlich hat sie gecheckt, dass ich ihr das Parfum schenken will. Sie will mir jetzt auch was schenken, okay, jetzt muss ich es kaufen. Problem war, ich hatte kurz überlegt, es nicht zu schenken, weil ich in der Zwischenzeit herausgefunden habe, wie teuer es war. Ich war also in diesem Laden und es war viel zu teuer. Aber wie teuer kann ein Parfum sein? Es war halt so ein spezielles. Du hast doch schon einen Kanister dann geholt, einen Fünf-Liter-Kanister. Sagen wir so, es war nicht das, was man so bei Douglas bekommt, sondern es war ein spezielles anderes Parfum, was ich in so einem SpeciLaden hier in Köln nur bekommen konnte. Die hatten aber auch, das Date war halt so ein paar Tage bevor, das konnte ich uns nicht mehr bestellen groß oder so was. Also ich musste es in dem Laden kaufen. Während ich im Laden stand, kam und ich den Preis gesagt bekommen hab, der lag bei 200 Euro. Mhm. Oh, ich hab mir gedacht, nee, ich war kurz am Umdrehen, lese die Nachricht von ihr, du hast dann noch einen Plattenspieler, oder? Denk mir, ja fuck, sie schenkt mir jetzt was, weil sie denkt, ich schenke ihr dieses Parfum. Warum schenkt sie mir nur eine Platte? Das ist viel zu wenig im Verhältnis, das macht gar keinen Sinn. Und hat dann gesagt, ja komm, fuck it, ich kauf das jetzt einfach. Das war so ein spezielles Parfum und die hatten nur die grössere Grösse von dem Flacon.
Machen wir uns auch alles französisch in diesem Wort Kosmos, Parfum.
Alles Flacon, das ist alles so. Das ist die Hälfte des Preises.
Oh Gott, also habe ich dann für 200 Euro dieses Parfum gekauft.
Das ist albern, einfach nur.
Wir haben dieses Date, sie gibt mir zuerst ihr Geschenk.
Was ist eine Platte, die sie nicht mehr gekauft hat, sondern die sie noch hatte rumliegen hatte und grob mit mir verbunden hatte, aber gar keine Beziehung zu irgendwas hatte. Wir hatten nur über Bands gesprochen und Musik, die wir mögen. Nein, nichts davon, einfach eine Platte, die sie noch hatte. Die weg musste eigentlich. Primär weg musste, weil sie jetzt auch umzieht. Es war aber nicht der Argo-Soundtrack, oder? War der Argo-Soundtrack, er war die Argo-Blu-Ray, hat sie dann geschenkt. Und ich habe ihr dann dieses Parfüm geschenkt. Und seitdem ist Funkstille, muss man sagen. Oh! Also, ich hätte es noch verschenkt dann. Moment, aber hattest du das Gefühl, dass das jetzt irgendwie too much ist in dem Moment, oder hat sie sich gefreut? Nee, ich habe es dann zum Thema gemacht, was die Kette war, und dass ich dann auch nicht mehr zurück konnte, weil ich dachte, sie wüsste, was sie dann bekommt. Moment mal, du hast ihr gesagt, ich dachte, du schenkst mir was Tolles, also schenke ich dir auch was Tolles, jetzt hast du mir aber gar nichts Tolles geschenkt, das hast du komplett offen gelegt. Nee, was ich ihr gesagt habe ist, ich bin mir sicher, dass du dachtest, dass ich dir das Parfum schenke, weil ich nach dem Flakon gefragt habe und konnte dann nicht mehr da da raus so richtig. Dann hatten die das aber so eine große... Sie waren gezwungen, dir das zu kaufen. Dann hatten die nochmal die große... Ich schippte hier nochmal die Quittung. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass du es umtauschen würdest und mir das Geld zurück schrie. Aber ja, und dann... Das Letzte, was ich glaube ich bekomme von ihr, ist die Nachricht, holy shit, ich habe es gerade gegoogelt, bist du verrückt oder sowas. Und dann tatsächlich Umzug und seitdem, ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, fuck, ja, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist dritte Klasse all over again. Aber ich fand es lustig, weil das offen zu spielen war dann auch lustig. Ja klar, das ist so offen. Immer offen spielen. Weil ich denke mir, in dem Moment, wo ich gefragt habe, hast du das Bild von Flakon, war klar, was ich ihr schenke. Und da ist eigentlich schon der Zug abgefahren. Naja. Zu teure Geschenke sind kein Spaß. Aber ich finde, du hast da nicht viel falsch gemacht in der Geschichte. Eigentlich hast du gar nichts falsch gemacht. Ich habe einer Frau, die ich nicht lange kenne, 200 Euro Verfolgung geschenkt. Ja, aber mein Gott. Das fehlt mir an anderen Ecken jetzt. Also ehrlich gesagt, muss ich auch sagen, ich kauf lieber ein teures Geschenk, von dem ich weiss, dass es der Person gefällt, als dass ich auf eigene Faust irgendwie so ein 15 Euro Hanuta-Box oder sowas kauf, keine Ahnung, wo ich dann mir denke, scheiße, das ist kein gutes Geschenk. Ich zahle lieber das Dreifache an Preis mit dem Wissen, dann habe ich ein gutes Gewissen, dass ich weiß, dass es gut ankommt. Also ich habe da gar nichts dagegen. Und wenn es wirklich so eine einmalige Sache ist, wie jetzt irgendwie, wir sehen uns länger nicht. Und es war genau das Parfum, was sie hatte, was sie damals geschenkt bekommen hat von irgendwem Fremden. Ich habe herausgefunden, wo man es kaufen kann und so. Das kannst du tatsächlich in einem Ort in Köln kaufen. In so einem weirden Seitengass und so. Das war ganz cool eigentlich, dass ich das herausgefunden habe. Naja, aber das stimmt schon, weil ich habe neulich aus Versehen in Lego Masters reingeschaut, diese Sendung, die es jetzt gibt auf RTL, wo irgendwie so die besten Lego-Bauer gesucht wurden. Und am Ende haben die Pokal bekommen natürlich und Preisgeld so 25.000 Euro oder sowas, aber auch Product Placement eine Schachtel Merci. Wirklich? Und es war das grosse Finale dieser Sendung, die jetzt über Monate lang lief, die haben alle erstmal eine Schachtel Merci bekommen und ich fand das, Product Placement hat Messi sich teuer bezahlen lassen, Stork oder Ferrero wahrscheinlich, ne? Keine Ahnung. Ja. Hat wahrscheinlich sehr viel Geld kosten lassen, dafür, dass sie dann da beworben wurden. Genial, aber hat diese ganze Preisverleihung so egal gemacht, weil die erst mal eine Schachtel Messi bekommen haben. Aber was ist wenigstens die große? Nein, die kleine Schachtel Messi. Kleine Schachtel Merci, wo der Moderator schon so die Nougat-Dinger rausgefingert hat. Ja, Marzipan und Nougat ist weg. Sorry, ich hab dich hier. Und es ist auch Mokka. Wir haben Backstage so wenig. Können wir mal überhaupt. Ja genau, Mokka ist noch übergegeben. Und wir haben hier alle erst mal eine Schachtel Merci bekommen, wo ich dachte, jetzt können die auch noch 25.000 Euro bekommen. Es steht alles irgendwie in dem Schatten der Messi-Parkung. Du willst nicht irgendwie bei Olympia-Goldenmedaille noch irgendwie eine Schachtel Messi dazu bekommen. Das geht nicht. Du kannst niemandem nicht eine Goldmedaille ohne eine Schachtel Messi schenken. Eins von beiden. Du kannst nicht irgendwie diese 200 Euro Flasche Parfüm schenken und dazu irgendwie noch so ein Duplo oder so. Das geht nicht. Ja, aber so eingepackt. Ja, das geht nicht. Das ist auch meine Mutter immer, was mich immer nervt, die packt immer so, dann Weihnachten verpackt sie manchmal Geld, irgendwie mit Süßigkeitenkram oder sowas. Und dann packt sie das immer ein. Und ich freue mich immer über das haptische Geschenk, weil über Geld freut man sich ja nicht so richtig.
Ich freue mich schon über haptische Geschenke,
aber dann ist immer in den Süßigkeiten
irgendwas halt so... Das magst du nicht.
Ich mache das auch immer.
Süßigkeiten einpacken. Ja, ich finde
das ist gut, weil du kannst beim Auspacken
noch was naschen.
Weil das Auspacken ist ja eigentlich die
wahre Freude. Über Süßigkeiten
einpacken, nie denkt man
an Süßigkeiten. Nein, also ich packe die Süßigkeiten nicht ein,
ich klebe die Süßigkeiten...
Der Dritte ist ein, ich klebe die Süßigkeiten teilnahmslos auf die Packung drauf. Dass du noch so ein schönes Karamell-Dove nebenbei noch schlürfen kannst. Meine Mutter hat immer diese große Toffee-Vehrpackung, diese drei Toffee-Vehrpackung, diese große, das Skibrett und hat immer so Merci oder so, packt die dann in Geschenkpapier ein. Nee, das ist Quatsch. Und da steht dann irgendwas ein Umschlag drauf und das gibt es mir dann immer. Ich freue mich immer so über dieses, ich denke, ist das ein Buch, was ist das, ist ein Bild? Nein, das ist eine Merci-Packung. Werbung. Flotin, bist du gut versichert? Um ehrlich zu sein, ich bin ein Mensch des Risikos, ich habe keine Versicherung, mir ist das alles zu blöd, da musst du ständig irgendein Papierkram ausfüllen, da musst du irgendwie deine ewigen Hotlines rumhängen und so, das ist mir zu blöd. Aber ist doch wirklich so, oder? Es ist was superessentielles, aber bei mir ist immer diese bürokratische Hürde, jetzt irgendwie eine Hotline zu hängen oder sowas, ist so gross, dass ich glaube ich da ernsthaft gerade in massiven Problemen stecke, wenn mal was passiert. Was halt saudumm ist eigentlich, weil im Endeffekt ist eine Versicherung ja wichtig. Ja, das hat ja eine Daranschberechtigung. Deswegen haben wir, glaube ich, was für euch, liebe Podcast-Sofo-Hörer, nämlich GetSafe. GetSafe ist nämlich eine Versicherung, die komplett ohne diesen ganzen Papierkram funktioniert. Es ist einfach eine App oder eine Website, je nachdem, wie ihr das am liebsten benutzen wollt. Und ihr könnt innerhalb von drei Minuten Versicherung abschliessen und ihr könnt ihr auch genauso schnell wieder kündigen. Alles in der App, komplett papierlos, muss nicht irgendeinen Quatsch einscannen oder irgendwie so rum auf den Brief warten, sondern alles nur über die App. Da könnt ihr zum Beispiel eine hafliche Versicherung abschliessen für drei Euro 60 im Monat, nach Hausrat, für zwei Euro 99 im Monat. Und falls ihr euch jetzt sagt, ja, ich brauche ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit in meinem Leben, ich will eine Versicherung haben, dann können wir euch da auch noch ein kleines Kirschchen obendrauf anbieten, denn mit dem Gutscheincode Ufo 150, Ufo 150, bekommt ihr 150 Euro Guthaben, mit dem ihr dann ganz fantastische Versicherungen euch besorgen könnt. Das Ganze gibt es bei Google Play und im App Store und über die Website hellGetSafe.com Werbung Und apropos Weihnachten, natürlich der alljährliche Konsumrausch wird kommen und Stefan, du hattest mich gebeten, meine letzten zehn Amazon-Einkäufe zu sammeln. Ich habe die Liste zusammengestellt. So, aber die ist nicht kuratiert oder sowas. Die ist nicht kuratiert, nein, null kuratiert. Und wow! Also, macht das mal. Schaut euch mal eure letzten zehn Produkte bei Amazon an. Man lernt eine Menge über sich. Und ich glaube, also ich habe überlegt, angenommen es gäbe jetzt eine neue Dating-App, wo man weder Bild noch sonst was von einer Person sieht, sondern nur die letzten zehn Käufe. Da dachte ich mir würde ich mich daten und ich glaube nein. Und macht einfach mal den Test bei euch, schaut euch mal die letzten zehn Produkte an, die ihr bestellt habt bei Amazon und guckt, ist das eine sympathische Person, mit der ihr den Rest eures Lebens verbringen wollen würde oder eher nicht. Wie sympathisch war ich? Du warst sehr sympathisch. Ja? Auch dieses Spiel, das war toll, diese Klemmen, das war super, fand ich toll. Also, wir fangen mal an. Das letzte Protokoll, das ich mir gekauft habe, war, du weisst, ich hänge immer noch dem Ersten Weltkrieg hinterher und habe mir gekauft das Buch Tannenberg von Erich Ludendorff. Und Erich Ludendorff war tatsächlich der Befehlshaber der Schlacht um Tannenberg und hat selbst ein Buch über diese Schlacht geschrieben. Was ich spannend fand, war oft liest man ja nur Geschichten von Historikern oder so, aber da hat die Person selber... Sympathisch in den letzten zehn Einkäufen. War sich unsympathisch, wenn man jetzt zum Kontext hätte, dass nicht nur die erste Schlacht ist, über die du liest, sondern du schon sehr viele andere Bücher über Schlachten hast, immer würde man denken, ja, Freak. Absolut. Bei den letzten hundert Einkäufen würde ich wahrscheinlich denken, Freak, so gerade sympathisch war. Ja, absolut. Vor allem diese Bücher sind auch immer sehr hässlich. Da macht sich niemand Gedanken darüber, wie kann man das cool gestalten. Weil Tannenberg das selber designen wollte. Ludendorff, extrem hässlich. So, davor ... Erich Tannenberg über die Schlacht vom Ludendorff. Nein. Ach so. Und davor bestellt 200 Gramm Rotbusch-Tee. Roybusch. Rotbusch, hier steht Rotbusch. Ich glaube, es ist der deutsche ... Aber im Politikum. Naja, also hier steht Rotbusch-Tee Bio aus Südafrika minus Roybusch aus Südafrika minus. Roybusch. Das ist ja verrückt. Geteilt durch. Guck mal, wir haben alle drei Schreibweisen. Wir haben Rotbusch, Roy, BOS und dann nochmal Roybusch. Also ich glaube, der Verkäufer weiß selber nicht, wie es heißt. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie es heißt. Rotbusch minus Roybusch minus Roybusch gleich. ... Niemand weiß, wie dieser T heisst, aber ich glaube, man sagt einfach so ähnlich wie Rotbusch. Weil das heisst, ist er auch so Sträuchermässig. Ich liebe Roybusch-Tee. Ist er so holzig eigentlich, so büschig, deswegen sagt einfach Roybusch. Niemand weiss es. Ich glaube, die wollen einfach alle Schreibweisen abdecken, damit jeder, der danach sucht, findet, was er möchte. SEO. Davon 200 Gramm. 200 Gramm? 200 Gramm. Aber in was sind die verpackt? Einfach so loser Tee. Nee, so Papierpackungen und dann kam es das selber an. Und du findest Amazon den besten Händler für Tee. Ja, ich probiere mich da so ein bisschen durch und auch da... Tee-Konnoisseur Florian empfiehlt Amazon. Und auch da habe ich letztens ausprobiert, weil wir gerade beim Thema Brew sind, Cold Brew Tee, einfach schön Tee in der Kanne über Nacht im Kühlschrank stehen lassen. Anscheinend soll das schonender sein, ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet. Schonend? Keine Ahnung. Was heißt das schonend? Also bei allem stelle ich mir vor, der Geschmack wird aus den Teeblättern halt so rausgerissen, wohingegen bei schonend wird es eher so rausgekitzelt. Es klingt nach wenig Geschmack. Es klingt nach demselben Geschmack. Aber das eine ist eher wie so eine Razzia, so drei Uhr nachts an der Tür hämmern, jemanden aus dem Bett ziehen und das schonend ist eher so, entschuldigen, könnten Sie ganz kurz, guten Morgen, hallo, wer hat denn da noch deine Euglein, es ist schon neun Uhr, ich mach mal den Vorhang auf, ich mach mal hier schon mal den Vorhang auf, bleib noch ein bisschen liegen, nee, es k nach weniger Geschmack. Es klingt nach einer Weichei-Version. Weil am Ende stehst du auch auf. Also du bist der Geschmack. Ja, aber du bist nicht spielerfasernackt rausgerissen worden aus deinem Lebensumfeld. Das will ich schmecken. Ich will diese Todesschreie vom Räubersteh schmecken. Ja, eigentlich schon. Also davon 200 Gramm. Der Einkauf davor war dieser Popschutz, weil einer von uns hat einen Popschutz verloren. Das ist immer dieses kleine Stoffding, was vor dem Mikrofon ist, damit man ja, man sieht gut aus. Hört den Unterschied bei den letzten Folgen? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ja, und den habe ich bestellt, von meinem eigenen Geld habe ich bezahlt, um dieses Podcast-Projekt zu unterstützen.
Das war Einkauf Nummer drei. Einkauf Nummer vier. Hundert Gramm Räubusch Vanille. Habe ich es mal richtig krachen lassen. Hundert Gramm Räubusch Vanille. Aber nur hundert Gramm. Nur hundert Gramm, das war mir ein bisschen zu verrückt. Da dachte ich mir, von Vanille, mh, erst mal Piano. Erst mal Piano.
Erst mal Piano.
Aber warum denn, also ich bin immer so ein bisschen skeptisch, was so traditionelle herkömmliche Teesorten plus Vanille ist, so wie Vanille Coke. Naja, aber wenn du überlegst, ja das stimmt schon, aber Vanille ist ja halt auch einfach nur irgend so ein Busch. Das heisst, wenn du jetzt halt Räubusch und dann hast du halt so ein Kraut, so ein Unkraut, Vanillekraut,
Bourbon,
haust du da mit rein, ist ähnlich.
Hat mich auch nicht so ganz überzeugt. Ich bin da total
bei dir. Ich bin da eher Purist.
Und dieses Vanillezusatz gibt es da auch ganz viele Tees
so hier. Ja, wenn dann selber händisch
hinzufügen. Nee, das ist Quatsch. Ja, du willst
die eigene Mischung, du willst den Blend eigentlich selber herstellen.
Das war Einkauf Nummer vier.
Einkauf Nummer fünf, ein Buch auf Französisch, Roland Barth, Mythologies, Fantastisch, habe ich schon auf Deutsch gelesen, toll. So, jetzt kommen wir zu einem Produkt Nummer sechs. Es ist so, muss ich vielleicht ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Es ist eine Gesichtsmaske, eine Aloe Vera Gesichtsmaske. Und jetzt möchte ich kurz dazu was sagen. Es gibt verschiedene Käufe im Leben. Es gibt den vernünftigen, wohldurchdachten Kauf, das brauche ich, das will ich, das ist preisgünstig. Es gibt den Impulsivkauf. Es gibt aber auch eine Art von Kauf, die, glaube ich, jeder kennt. Und zwar den Gif-Kauf. Man sieht ein Gif und man denkt sich, das brauche ich. Und ich habe auf Facebook, es war ein Facebook-Gif, die unterste Stufe des Gifs. Ein Facebook-Gif. Ein Facebook-Gif. Von diesen weirden Drecks-Facebook-Seiten, die so Produkte bewerben, die eigentlich niemand braucht und niemand will, aber die visuell gut aussehen.
Und da war so ein GIF von so einer Gesichtsmaske, die so abgezogen wurde von der Haut und die so aus den Hautporen, so aus jeder Pore, wie bei so einer Erdbeere, so ganz kleine Teile.
War die schwarz? War das eine schwarze Maske?
Nee, grün.
Ich kenne die nur in schwarz und habe mir die auch bei Amazon bestellt.
Ja, aber ich habe wirklich nicht das Gefühl, unreine Haut oder irgendetwas zu haben. Aber allein das zu sehen, dieses voll und ganz Reinigende, so dieses aus jeder winzigen Pore, wo man ja nicht das Gefühl hat, dass man so normal auf der Wange irgendwie da irgendwas drin ist. So Talg drin. Aber da ist irgendwas drin. Und allein die Vorstellung, das abzuziehen und dann so komplett gereinigt zu sein, das hat mich dazu verleitet zu sagen, ich will das mal ausprobieren. Weil ist das an diesem Gift eine besonders unreine Haut oder hat jeder so eine Erdbeerhaut? Weiß man nicht. Und dann habe ich mir die bestellt. Bei mir hatte ich das auch, ich hätte den schwarz. Aber das war auch so eine Masse. ne? War eine Masse, dann lässt du die trocknen und dann ziehst du die ab.
Und dann hängt da schon ein bisschen was dran.
Und weil es schwarz ist, siehst du, ist es auch noch krass,
weil es ja oft heller Talg ist.
Aber es hing halt bestimmt drei Stunden in meinem Bart.
So.
Und ich hab so lange, bis die Haut so mega rot und entzündet war, weil ich das nicht wegbekommen habe, war so nervig, diese Scheiße. Aber hattest du diesen Erdbeereffekt, dass da so ganz viel rausgezogen ist? Keinen Erdbeereffekt. Ja, ich habe dann diese Maske aufgetragen, absolut katastrophal gelaufen. Also hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert, ich war viel zu ungeduldig, man musste die irgendwie so eine halbe Stunde einwirken lassen. Habe ich nicht hinbekommen. Nach 15 Minuten habe ich es nicht mehr ausgehalten und konnte es. Ich war einfach zu ungeduldig, habe versucht, mir die von der Haut zu ziehen. Hat nicht funktioniert, die war einfach noch nicht fest. Es war alles schmierig, schleimig. Ich hatte die Hälfte im Haar, was absolut furchtbar war, natürlich die andere Hälfte im Bart, weil ich da einfach wild über mein Gesicht gestrichen hatte, ich hatte
was im Auge, es war ganz, ganz
schrecklich, es war absolute
Katastrophe, nicht ein Hauch von Erdbeereffekt,
gar nichts. Aber fünf von fünf Sterne.
Fünf von fünf Sterne gegeben und ich habe mir
zwei weitere Schaden bestellt.
Aber war das so eine Einmalsache oder
könntest du es nochmal? Nein, das war eine
Einmalsache und... Nee, weil
das nur für einmal ist, diese Verpackung? Nee, ich glaube, ich habe da so ein Drittel rausgenommen von dieser Schale. Kannst du mir das mal mitbringen? Ja. Weil, dann würde ich es auch mal gerne ausprobieren, einfach nochmal. Ja, ich habe mir dann überlegt, aber auch, wenn man damit einmal anfängt, muss man damit weitermachen. Also ich habe das bei mir bei manchen Körperhygienedingen bemerkt. Wenn man damit einmal anfängt, also es gibt gewisse Dinge, die hat man davor nie beachtet.
Nasenhaare zum Beispiel. Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt meines Lebens nie dran gedacht. Aber sobald du einmal anfängst, die irgendwie rauszuziehen oder mit so einem Nasenhaar entfernen, ab dann denkst du dir, ja, ab jetzt muss ich jede Woche mich um meine Nasenhaare kümmern. Und das ist so ein Moment in deinem Leben, ab jetzt spielt das eine Rolle.
Und ich dachte mir, irgendwann habe ich gar keinen Platz mehr in meinem Leben, weil ich jede Woche dann die Augenbrauen, weil du denkst dann immer, du fühlst dich dann irgendwie falsch und unrein, wenn du es dann nicht machst. Wohingegen all die Dinge davor hast du ja dich nie unrein gefühlt. Nee, das stimmt schon. Bei mir ist es zugekommen, mein Nacken, also mein Nacken wächst schneller, der Nackenhaare, als der nächste Friseurtermin kommt. Und jetzt haben wir dann so ein paar, am Set waren dann immer auch so Maskenler, die sind dummerweise immer hinter mir, und die ganzen Maskenler haben immer gesagt, ich will so gerne deinen Nacken ausrasieren, Stefan. Und jetzt ist das ein Thema bei mir. Ja. War es vorher nicht? Und jetzt machst du es selber, oder? Ich bin vorher glücklich. Nein, jetzt gehe ich irgendwie zwischendurch noch mal zum Nachschneiden, zum Friseur und zum Kack. Ja, genau. Jetzt fühlst du dich schlecht. Ich glaube auch, dass das Beste ist, einfach gar nichts zu machen. Nein, lass die Fingernägel lang werden. Was soll passieren? Ja, lass die lang werden. Und zum Beispiel habe ich auch das Gefühl, ich hatte trockene Hände und habe dann immer Feuchtigkeitscreme benutzt. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, je mehr Feuchtigkeitscreme ich benutze, desto trockener werden die Hände, weil der Körper faul wird. Weil der denkt, ich muss überhaupt keine eigene Feuchtigkeit mehr produzieren. Jetzt werden die Hände trocken. Deswegen glaube ich, vielleicht ist es besser, gar nichts zu machen. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, vielleicht ist es mit dieser dummen Maske keine gute Idee. Weil sonst habe ich das Gefühl, jede Woche das machen zu müssen, sonst fühle ich mich schmutzig. Und deswegen konnte ich diesen Kosmetikwahn von mir weisen. Aber auch natürlich durch, muss man sagen, reine Dummheit, habe ich es einfach nicht hinbekommen. Weiter geht's, das würde dich, glaube ich, sehr freuen, Reklambuch, der Ring des Nibelungen. Oh, was? Ja, schön bestellt, wollte ich mal gelesen haben, weil man versteht den Text ja nicht, wenn man es so hört, der Regel. Man versteht den Text nicht, dann lese ich das nebenbei und habe jetzt schon so, glaube ich, die ersten zwei Szenen gehört. Einfach mal Du hörst es dann und liest den Text dazu. Ja, genau. Cool. Warum nicht? Dann neunter Einkauf, ein Ladekabel für einen Game Boy Advanced. So. Und dann zehnter Einkauf in, glaube ich, krassem Gegensatz zum Ladekabel für einen Game Boy Advanced. Eine fünf Liter Mülltüte für einen Badezimmermülleimer. Okay. So, und jetzt Thema Badezimmermülleimer. Ja, Thema Badezimmermülleimer. Thema Badezimmermülleimer ist ja etwas, das man als Mann, glaube ich, erstmal einfach nicht braucht. Habe ich zumindest nie gebraucht. Man hat mir aber gesagt, dass Frauen durchaus darauf angewiesen sind und ein Mann von Welt durchaus einen Badezimmermülleimer haben sollte. Sogar einen, der am besten Deckel hat. Mit Deckel, absolut. Damit Frauen sich nicht genieren. Nein, Deckel, schwarze Mülltüte. Ich habe mich mit dem Thema beschäftigt und habe mir jetzt auch einen Badezimmer-Mülleimer zugelegt. Und einfach als Zeichen des Erwachsenseins, als Zeichen der Reife habe ich mir das zugelegt. Habe allerdings leider bei den Müllbeuteln die Anzahl übersehen und es sind 150 Müllbeute geworden. Also ich sag mal so, man muss nicht pessimistisch sein gegenüber meiner Zukunft mit dem weiblichen Geschlecht, aber ob es wirklich 150, 5 Liter Müllbeutel, also insgesamt 750 Liter Badezimmermülleimer Inhalt, ob ich das noch schaffe in meinem Leben, weiß ich nicht. Aber mir ist es auch passiert. Aber ich habe sie parat. Mir ist es auch passiert, weil ich habe jetzt so einen neuen Mülleimer, weil ich ungesucht bin, habe ich eine neue Küche, einen neuen Mülleimer und der ist so speziell, deswegen hat er so spezielle Mülltüten. Bei dir ist auch alles fancy. Die waren leer, ja, die waren leer, jetzt habe ich nachbestellt, habe direkt so drei Packs davon gekauft, aber das war nicht jeweils ein, also das war nicht eine Rolle, ich dachte, ich habe drei Rollen bestellt. Nein, das waren, jetzt habe ich dreimal acht Rollen bestellt. Da habe ich so große Kisten lagern jetzt bei mir, wo Mülltüten drin sind. Aber auf einer Seite auch schön, dass man sich jetzt in den nächsten drei Jahren keine Gedanken mehr machen muss um Müllbeutel. Total. Und du, das ist wirklich ein Thema, um Badezimmer und Mülltüten, weil das Problem ist, die sind halt so klein, die kann man eigentlich für nichts anderes verwenden, als für Badezimmer Mülleimer. Mein Problem ist nur, in meinem Badezimmer ist keine Toilette. Ich habe eine separate Toilette. Meine Toilette ist nur ein Raum. Und da brauche ich ja den Badezimmer Mülleimer. Da ist nichts drin außer der Toilette. Das ist nur eine Toilette, ein Waschbecken, ein Spiegel.
Da ist der Mülleimer.
Nee, und da bräuchte ich ja den Mülleimer.
Warum?
Als Mann von Vale für Frauen.
Braucht man den nicht eher so bei diesem Fertig-Frisch-Mach-Badezimmer dann?
Also, mir wurde gespiegelt, Frauen brauchen, wenn sie ihre Tage haben, auf dem Klo einen Mülleimer zum Wegschmeissen von Müll. Okay. So. Gut, das ist jetzt natürlich der Next Level Frage, wenn du zwei Badezimmer hast. Richtig. Ich würde dann einfach zwei Mülleimer holen. Ich habe 150 Tüten, mir ist das egal. Ich kann in jedes Zimmer, in jeder Ecke Mülltüten hängen, so viele Zimmer. Mach das mal. Aber das ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt, weil es so klein und so, und es ist auch nicht so schön dann, wenn da so ein Mülleimer drinsteht. Und da habe ich mal gefragt, was machst du denn jetzt, wenn da kein Mülleimer drinsteht? Und da meinte sie, ja, dann würde man das umständlich irgendwie nehmen und dann wegschmeissen im normalen Mülleimer. Das ist alles so ein bisschen komisch. Es tut mir auch leid, als Mannhirn ist man da einfach nicht darauf geeicht, dass man da auch einen Mülleimer bräuchte. Das stimmt, deswegen hier der Tipp an alle, holt euch einfach einen Badezimmermülleimer. Ich habe ein paar Tüten übrig, schreibt mir, ich schicke euch ein paar Tüten. Ja, kannst du mir ein paar Tüten geben? Wir packen das zusammen an. Schwarze Beutel zu erkauft? Ja. Das verstehe ich nicht. Warum hast du denn Farbe Schwarz gewählt? Na, ich dachte, möglichst diskret. Hä? Schwarz. Oder warum nicht? Aber du machst doch den... Sag mir jetzt bitte nicht, dass meine 150 Tüten falsch sind. Stefan, jetzt machst du mich mal rös. Ich verstehe nicht, warum die diskret sein müssen so sehr, weil du lehrst die ja aus wahrscheinlich auch. Ja eben, gerade dann müssen sie ja diskret sein. Aber du siehst ja dann auch den Inhalt von oben rein, du kannst ja reingucken. Oh Gott. Ich verstehe nicht, warum schwarz bei dir sein muss. Aber schwarz ist jetzt nicht falsch, oder? Nee, nicht falsch. Gut. So ein bisschen zu viel. Also dieses Notch-zu-viel- Gedanken rein. Welche Farbe denn sonst? Diese normalen halt, die sind ein bisschen umweltfreundlicher. Schwarz ist normal für Müll. Das glaube ich nicht. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Wenn du sagst Mülltüte, Müllsack, dann denkt man an ... Nein. Doch. Nein.
Es gibt dieses durchsichtigere Weiss, dann gibt es dieses cremigere Weiss.
Nein, du denkst an Schwarz.
Blau.
Der klassische Müllsack ist Schwarz.
Blau gibt es auch viel. Mit diesen fertigen Trummi-Bändern drin.
Jetzt wird es albern.
Nee, aber ja, das waren meine Amazon-Stellungen und ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich daten würde danach.
Und der Mülleimer? Wo hast du den gekauft? Ich glaube, das war noch elf. Ich glaube, das war elf. Ich habe übrigens so Spaß daran, Wohnungen einzurichten, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Und ich glaube, dass ich ein guter Interior-Designer wäre. Und ich bin mit der festen Überzeugung wirklich. Und ich werde so gerne ein neues Projekt. Ich hoffe so sehr, auch so ganz eigennützig rate ich Leuten, aber aus meinem Umfeld umzuziehen, einfach damit ich denen helfen kann. Ich habe gesagt, gib mir ein Budget und ich richte dir die Wohnung ein. Aber hast du nicht auch mit einer Innenarchitektin zusammengearbeitet für die Wohnung? Nein, nein, eine Eine Schreinerin das meinst du wahrscheinlich. Die sollte mir dann einen Schrank, einen Einbauschrank, den ich brauchte, machen. Aber nee, nee, ich habe alles selber eingerechnet. Und das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, deswegen hoffe ich die ganze Zeit auf das nächste Projekt. Ich denke mir eigentlich so, dass ich mir da voll aufgehen. Falls ihr gerade umzieht, Stefan Handyman Tizze kommt vorbei und hilft euch. Zumindest haut man ein paar Ideen in den Raum, die ihr euch wahrscheinlich alle nicht leisten könnt. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Gebt mir ein Budget und für das Budget finde ich auf jeden Fall die richtige Einrichtung für die Wohnung. Ist ja nicht das teuerste, das beste. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber ich finde es so interessant, weil du bist ja, du wirst ja geboren und dann lebst du erst mal bei deinen Eltern und erlebst da einen Haushalt mit unendlich vielen Dingen, mit vielen kleinen Sachen, wo du dir denkst und dann ziehst du um. Ja, wenn du da geboren bist, oft ist es ja ein Haus, wo schon länger drin die Eltern gewohnt haben, wo sie schon Scheiße ansammelt, eine Menge Kacke. Und wo du auch aber lauter so kleine Sachen hast und dann ziehst du um und wohnst alleine und kaufst dir erst mal nur das Nötigste. Dann merkst du, ach scheiße, ich brauche schon so einen Quirr. Ich brauche von dem ganzen kleinen Scheiß auch, der da war. Genau, ach scheiße, ich brauche schon so ein Reibeding. Und Stück für Stück füllt man dann wieder den Haushalt, den man von den Eltern aufkennt, auf. Stück für Stück, so wie jetzt bei mir mit dem Badezimmermülleimer, wo man merkt, ah, deswegen, und jetzt brauchen wir den. Und erst denkt man sich so, ich mache das viel cleverer, ich habe das Nötigste, ich brauche das alles nicht. Und dann Stück für Stück merkt man, deswegen. Das war der Ursprung. Und erst denkt man sich so, ich mach das viel cleverer, ich hab das Nötigste, ich brauch das alles nicht und dann Stück für Stück merkt man, nee, das braucht man eigentlich schon. Man braucht eigentlich alles davon, bis auf diese weirden Statuen oder sowas, diese Beethoven-Büste. Du, ich bin mir sicher, also ich bin da mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so sicher, dass nicht irgendwann der Punkt kommt, wo ich denke, jetzt, man braucht diese Statue, damit man da die Tür dahinter so einklemmt, falls man was reintragen muss. Buchstütze, Buchstütze! Und man denkt sich, ja, das ist ja gar nicht so dumm, das hat alles seinen Sinn. Zurück zu deinem Badezimmermülleimer, ist das so ein, so mit dem Drehding oben, weißt du, mit diesem halb kugelförmigen Deckel, der diese quirlige
kennst du den, was ich meine?
Kannst du mal gucken?
Der Klassiker, ist der Klassiker.
Aber auch bei Amson.
Ja, das ist glaube ich Einkauf 11 gewesen.
Der Klassiker, also so ein
mit dem unten dem Druckknopf,
wo man den aufmachen kann, oben den Deckel.
Der geht von alleine wieder zu.
Geht er langsam zu? Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich habe ihn noch nie geöffnet. Ich weiß nicht, wie der auf geht. Geht der langsam zu oder schnell zu?
Ich glaube, der klappt durchaus rapide mit einem Ohrendurchmach und Bein gehenden Klappgeräusch wieder zu.
Ich habe mit dem noch nicht so viel zu tun gehabt. Das ist ein Fremder. Das ist eigentlich ein Fremder in meiner Wohnung.
Ist okay so, ist halt ein Gast. Ist halt so nicht für mich, aber ist okay. Du willst ihn nie benutzen? Nee. Was macht man mit Müllbeuteln? Kann man Müllbeutel wegwerfen? Oder lässt man dann irgendwas auf? Du meinst so unbenutzte Müllbeutel? Ja. Ich glaube nicht. Du kannst auch Mülleimer nicht wegwerfen. Du kannst nicht einfach einen Mülleimer, das geht nicht. Also ich glaube, ich werde diese Müllsäcke auch nicht mehr los so schnell. Nee. Also da müsste ich schon, wow, eine Menge Erfolg haben. Du wirfst immer einen Müllbeutel weg. Du wirfst immer einen Müllbeutel in den Müll.
Nur einen.
Damit du das Raum-Zeit-Kontinuum nicht durchbrichst.
Aber so einen mal immer so ... Ja.
Weil das ist albern.
Nee, nicht wegwerfen.
Nein, nein, nein, überhaupt nicht.
Die kann man ja für viele Dinge verwenden.
Bestimmt finde ich da auch noch andere Verwendungsmöglichkeiten.
Ich habe zum Beispiel mal sehr erfolgreich einen Heissluftballon gebaut.
Aus einem Müllsack. Mit Kindern, die haben ... Weil es schon mal passiert ist, dass du so viele hattest. Nein. Kinder haben Spaß an Heissluftballons und dann kann man ... Ja, an richtigen. Nee, vielmehr an kleinen, die sie selber bauen können. So eine Mülltüte und dann hast du so eine Kerze oder irgendwas und dann müssen die gucken, wie steigt der, nein der steigt nicht, wie kriegen wir ihn noch leichter und dann müssen alle beratschlagen, wie kriegen wir ihn jetzt leichter, vielleicht eine grössere Tüte für mehr Luft und eine kleinere Tüte, die weniger wiegt und am Ende ist der Eisluftballon, kommt jetzt abgebrannt, kein einziges Mal geflogen, Tim ist mit schweren Verbändungen ins Krankenhaus gekommen. Ich hatte eine Rauchvergiftung am Ende, glaube ich, wirklich, weil ich so hart diese scheiß Flamme versucht habe zum Brennen zu bringen, indem ich da reingepustet habe. Und ich habe immer jedes Mal den Rauch eingeatmet und mir wurde echt schwindelig. Und so positiv ist die Geschichte eigentlich gar nicht. Nee, macht sich nach. Am Ende hat es nicht funktioniert und ich war schwer krank und Kinder haben gelernt, es bringt nichts, sich Mühe zu geben, weil am Ende klappt es eh nicht, am Ende geht dein ganzes Projekt in Flammen auf. Was sind das Wort, warst du der Erzieher dieser Geschichte? Du warst der Ziel? Ich war ein der Betreuer von so Ferienbetreuung, von der Allianz Versicherung, die ihre Kinder in so ein Camp geschickt hat, damit die wegfahren können und Ich habe auf die auch aufgefasst. Am Ende ist ein grosser Versicherungsschaden entstanden. Gross entstanden. Das Problem ist, am einfachsten funktioniert es, wenn du einfach eine Papiertüte anzündest. Dann fliegt die auch hoch. Ja, wie Teebeutel. Was halt natürlich nicht so cool ist, weil du willst halt irgendwas bauen. Ja, da soll ja irgendwie so ein kleines Männchen unten im Korb sitzen. Irgendwas in der Richtung. Das ist ja genauso frustrierend, wie wenn du irgendwie mit Kindern versuchst, ein Boot zu bauen. So jeder baut ein kleines Boot und wessen Boot schwimmt am besten? Und ein Kind nimmt halt einfach eine leere Plastikflasche und wirft es ins Wasser und sagt, meins schwimmt am besten. Und du denkst dir, toll, Jeremy, richtig gut gemacht. Richtig toll, hatten wir jetzt richtig Spaß mit dir. Wo ist Jeremy heute? Da habe ich aber mit meinem Anwalt drüber gesprochen, das ist nicht meine Schuld. Der ist leider, ich weiß nicht, ob ich darüber reden sollte, aber... In so einem Heisswiff-Ballon fliegt er immer noch. Das letzte Mal wurde er über Costa Rica gesehen. Jeremy, alles Gute da draußen,
viel, viel Erfolg und schau mal wieder vorbei.
Deine scheiß
PT-Flasche.
Vor allem, weil das halt alles so super
ordentlich war bei dieser ganzen
Ferienveranstaltung, hieß es
bei der Hauptbetreuerin,
da habe ich dann gesagt, ja,
ich habe die Idee, ich will mit den Kindern
Heusluftballons bauen,
und dann meinte die Betreuerin, naja, aber das müssen wir ja schon anmelden, wegen Luftraum. Man kann nicht einfach so Sachen steigen lassen. Und da dachte ich, ich bitte Sie, wir müssen doch jetzt nicht irgendwo bei der Luft- und Raumfahrtbehörde anmelden, dass wir mit Kindern aus Müllsäcken in die Raumfahrt einzusteigen, und zwar noch diese Woche. Also bei allem gebührenden Respekt. Aber jetzt reden sie Nonsens. Und diese meinte, nein, nein, nein, das muss schon alles seine Ordnung haben. Bei allem bis gerade noch gebührenden Respekt. Genau, ja. Bei allem in diesem Moment verlöschendem Respekt muss ich ihn jetzt mal in die Parade fahren. Und die meinte, nee, nee, das muss ja alles seine Ordnung haben, wir müssen das anmelden. Ich werde das anmelden, ich werde die Telefonate tätigen. Die war bestimmt cool so, als Jugendvorsäge. Das hat richtig Spaß gemacht. Warum hat man der dieses Camp gegeben? Wie ist das Camp? Weil sie wahrscheinlich gut mit Verantwortung umgehen kann, weil sie anscheinend sich gut um die Kinder kümmert. Camp Alliance. Und dann meinte sie, ja, ich melde das für morgen an. Und dann hat die halt tatsächlich anscheinend irgendwo in München bei irgendeiner Behörde angehoben und hat gesagt, guten Tag, wir würden gerne morgen brennende, flammbare Flugobjekte gen Himmel steigen lassen. In die bemannte Raumfahrt einsteigen. Durchaus. Wenn es schlecht läuft, bemannte Raumfahrt. Und umso peinlicher natürlich für mich, dass am Ende nichts geflogen ist. Sorry, wir warten noch darauf, dass sie in die bemankte Raumfahrt einsteigen. Und du so, ja, gleich. Ich stell dir immer nur so irgendeinen Fluglotsen am Flughafen vor, der mit seinem Radar immer so bieb, bieb und dann so eine, ja, Entschuldigung, Frau Hoppenreiter, da fliegt ja jetzt gar nichts. Oder Ingo, der aus dem Urlaub raus musste kurzfristig, weil er diesen Quadranten untersuchen muss an dem Abend.
Und dann kommt da nichts und dann ruft er dich an. Genau. Herr Bill, wo bleiben denn
ihre bemannten Buchzeuge?
Man hört bei dir nur so schreiend Kinder im Hintergrund.
Ja, ich glaube,
Jennifer hat gerade einen Durchbruch mit ihrer
Stroheim-Konstruktion. Wir versuchen
T-15, wir versuchen
was hochsteigen zu lassen.
Aber wie unangenehm, einfach ganz München war alarmiert, der Polizeiwachtmeister war informiert dafür, dass am Ende nichts geglückt ist.
Also es war, hat nicht funktioniert, auf ganzer Ebene nicht funktioniert.
Was eine Kackscheisse.
Federball gespielt und wir haben versucht, den Federball so hoch wie möglich zu schlagen, damit wir mindestens in den Luftraum von über München eindringen konnten mit irgendwas. Fluglotse Ingo kurz und kleinen Flecken hatte. Ah ne, ist ein Krümel im Radar. Also das war sehr, sehr enttäuschend, aber hat Spaß gemacht auf jeden Fall. Ja, dir wahrscheinlich, aber den Kindern ehrlich. Mir hat es riesen Spaß gemacht. Vor allem, naja, aber ich glaube, das ist bei vielen Projekten mit Kindern so, dass man am Anfang sagt, naja, damit die Kinder Spaß haben. Am Ende hat man aber so viel Ehrgeiz, dass man die Kinder gar nicht mehr mitmachen lässt, sondern sagt, ich will jetzt einfach nur einen fucking Heißhofer-Ballon steigen lassen. Und die Kinder langweilen sich, wenn man selber nur noch daran rumarbeitet und das Kind sagt, vielleicht können wir noch eine Blume drauflegen. Nein, das würde das Gewicht erhöhen und würde überhaupt nichts bringen aerodynamisch. Geh weg, Jennifer, mit deiner Blume. Ich mache das hier selber. Meine Frage, wart ihr, weil die sind ja jetzt in einem gewissen Alter, die Kinder. Was ist aus euch geworden? Hört ihr das Podcast-Sufo? War jemand von euch im Florentinville-Camp jemals, in einem der vielen berüchtigten Florentinville-Camps? Und was ist es euch geworden? Habt ihr damit mitgenommen aus der Lektion, dass, weil keiner gut sei, Kinder sind ja auch beeinflusst bei der Hinsicht, dass nichts irgendeinen Sinn hat? Hat Florentin-Will euch komplett zerstört fürs Leben oder gut vorbereitet, weil es ja auch gewisserweise coole Ideen waren? Also ich versuche gerade, es ist 2013 nach Berlin gezogen, das heißt es muss vor 2013 gewesen sein, also sagen wir mal so vor sieben, acht Jahren. Also wenn die damals neun, acht, zehn waren, sind die mittlerweile in einem Sprachnachricht fähigen Alter, also falls ihr tatsächlich aus dem Münchner Bereich kommt, eure Eltern bei der Allianzversicherung arbeiten, fragt mal, ob ihr auf so einem Ferienlager wart und ob da nicht irgendein hochmotivierter Aeronautiker. Ingenieur, der so macht bei Airbus, fängt jetzt eine Ausbildung an. Wie geil!
Ja, genauso wie ich ja auch mal auf einem Zivil-Lehrgang war und wir dann natürlich das, was gemacht haben, was man überall macht, so dieses Ei aus dem Fenster schmeissen. Du kriegst irgendwie so zehn Strohhalme und ein Taschentuch und musst dann halt irgendwas bauen, um den Fall zu federn von dem rohen Ei. Dann wirfst es in Gruppenarbeit und so gedöhnt. Und dann macht er wieder seinen Scheiss. Und wieder die Behörden angerufen. Es werden Dinge aus dem Himmel fallen. Werden aus dem ersten Stock ein Eiflugkörper gen Bodenschleudern. Schießt. Ja, das ist okay. Das ist okay. Generell müssen sie nicht mehr anrufen. Alles unter 400 Meter. Interessiert uns den Scheiss. Was sie mit ihrem Drachen, mit ihrem ferngestellten Flugzeug machen, hören Sie bitte auf, uns anzurufen. Bitte, bitte. Und dann macht halt jeder so sein Ding, man baut dann halt irgendwie so ein Kissen unterm Ei, oder halt irgendein Quatsch. Und dann aber... Es gab Kissen? Über diese Aufgabe gab es Kissen. Wer hat sich dann für was anderes entschieden? Man versucht halt aus den Strohhalmen irgendwie so ein Federsystem zu machen, egal. Und am Ende macht dann der Lehrgangsleiter, ruft dann nochmal alle zusammen und sagt, na ja, tatsächlich hat einmal vor acht Jahren jemand ein Konstrukt gebaut, dass nicht nur das Ei sanft zu Boden gefedert hat, sondern sogar an Höhe gewonnen hat. Und er studiert jetzt Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik an der Universität München. Und an den denke ich jedes Mal zurück, wenn wir diese Übung machen. Und ich dachte mir jedes Mal, was ist das für eine Geschichte von dieser legendären Person, die es irgendwie geschafft hat, aus zehn Strohhalmen und einem Taschentuch MacGyver-mäßig einen Hubschrauber zu bauen, der nicht nur das Ei zu Boden befördert hat, sondern das Ei anscheinend bis nach Costa Rica verfrachtet hat. Ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden. Niemand hatte Respekt genug, nachzufragen. Wir hatten alle so viel Angst. Erkennt man ja, man ist ja auch in so einer ... Man macht Gags, redet über die Pause schon mal, redet über das Wochenende. Man ist ja auch nicht in der Stimmung oft. Man ist nicht empfänglich als Schüler für ... Entschuldigung, was war das gerade? Hat jemand aus dem Strohhalm Helikopter gebaut? Man ist ja auch nicht in der Stimmung oft, man ist nicht empfänglich als Schüler für, Entschuldigung, was war das gerade? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Hat jemand aus dem Strohalm Helikopter gebaut? Man ist nicht im Mark Ruffalo Investigativ. Du kannst so eine Scheisse erzählen. Wo man mal sagt, Entschuldigung, Moment mal, haben Sie gerade gesagt, da hat jemand mit zehn Strohalmen ein Fluggerät gebaut, das an Höhe gewonnen hat? Was ein Ei Richtung Weltall befördert hat und wahrscheinlich heute noch fliegt? Ja. So viel Nonsens. Ja, aber wahrscheinlich, wenn dann immer nachgefragt hätte, der Lehrer gesagt, ah, hört doch jemand zu. Na gut, das sind die Gruppen, das ist so eine Pädagogik-Scheiße. Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Alle hören zu, aber alle denken sich, was, was? So viel Bullshit einfach. Aber gibt es den Lehrer noch? Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Tatsächlich. Können wir das mal retuschieren? Das Podcast UFO-Investigativ? Also vielleicht auch, ja, falls ihr euch das war. Wann war das? Wann habe ich Zivil gemacht? 2011? Keine Ahnung. Wow, jetzt wird es zu tage. Aber das war tatsächlich so. Und ich war ja der letzte Zivildienstlehrgang aller Zeiten. Ich habe einen Zivildienst gemacht und genau danach wurde die Wehrpflicht abgeschafft. Du hast so allgegessen, nehme ich an. Naja, die Verpflegung bei diesem Zivildienstlehrgang ist nicht gut. Du wirst auf die Front vorbereitet, auf die Sozialfront. Wieso das denn gehen? Was? Wie willst du denn da? Es kann ja kein Helikopter sein. Das Helikopter-Idee ist Quatsch. Ich weiß es nicht. Hitze und Hochsteigen ... Ja, oder du schaffst es, dass der Aufprall-Effekt so enorm ist, dass das Ei über die Ausgangshöhe gegen jedes newtonsche Gesetz hinausgeschleudert wird. wenn du irgendwie schaffst, die Kraft des Eis, die Kraft des Dotters irgendwie anzuzapfen für dein Fluggerät, dann ist, glaube ich, alles möglich. Hat der Helium da reingeballert oder was? Ich weiß es nicht. Wieso ist das nicht funktionieren? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist grosser Bullshit. Natürlich ist es grosser Bullshit, aber uns wurde das als Legende verkauft, von diesem einen Wunderkind, dass es irgendwie geschafft hat. Niemand weiss es und er hat das auch erzählt, so als hätte er auch nicht verstanden, wie es funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich wurde er einfach verarscht, wahrscheinlich haben die da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwas dran gebunden. Wer weiß, wer weiß. Vielleicht war es einfach ein Ulkbold, der da einfach dem Leiter da irgendwie einen Streich gespielt hat. Wenn es in Deutschland den Podcast The Mystery Show geben würde, würde ich das gerne einreichen. Als mein Rätsel, warum, wie ist das passiert? Wer war diese Person? Gab es das wirklich? Was macht die Person heute? Baut die immer noch aus Strohalm flugfähige V2-Raketen? Ich habe diesem Lehrgangsleiter eine richtig saftige negative Kritik verpasst.
Bei Jelp.
Bei zivilehrgangsleiter.org.
Wir haben am Ende so Zettel bekommen, dass wir den Lehrgang bewerten.
Und in vollem Bewusstsein, dass das der letzte Zivildienstlehrgang der Bundesrepublik Deutschland sein wird, aller Zeiten, habe ich dem trotzdem eine super negative Kritik geschrieben, weil er uns so viel Bullshit erzählt hat in diesen ganzen politischen Seminaren, die wir da hatten. Weil es gibt einmal so einen Zivillienstlehrgang zu praktischen Sachen, so wie trage ich einen Rollstuhl die Treppe runter, so ein Zeug, wo man sich denkt, ja, genau das braucht man als Zivi. Und dann gibt es aber noch einen zweiten Lehrgang zu so politischer Bildung, den man dann auch durchlaufen muss, wo einem einfach nur Nonsens beigebracht wird. Und was natürlich auch schwierig ist, weil natürlich da auch die Zivildienstleistenden aus unterschiedlichen Schulen natürlich kommen. Und ich will gar nicht sagen, dass man als Gymnastisch schon alles weiß, aber so die Grundlagen hat man halt schon mal gehört. Und dann in dieser politischen Diskussion wird es sehr schwierig, weil eigentlich dieser Lehrgangsleiter eigentlich diesen politischen Bildungsseminar genutzt hat, um uns vorzuwerfen, dass sich die Jugend überhaupt nicht mehr engagiert und dass niemand mehr auf die Strasse geht. Und wir damals, 68, wir sind damals auf die Strasse gegangen, wir haben uns von Tränengas beschissen lassen.
Und das war eigentlich der gesamte Bildungsinhalt, seine persönliche Agenda gegen die Jugend.
Und dann habe ich dem eine saftige Kritik hinterlassen und gesagt, hier, in ein paar Jahren Fridays for Future, da kannst du mal gucken. Vielleicht hat es gewirkt, vielleicht war er der Auslöser dieser ganzen Fridays for Future Bewegung, weil er der jungen Generation ins Gewissen geredet hat. Ich glaube, diesen Mann müssen wir ja auch nicht machen. Ja. Und den mal noch mal ein bisschen ins Verhör nehmen,
gucken, was er so noch zu sagen hat.
Ja, meldet euch. Was macht er vor allem jetzt?
Was macht er, nachdem alles
abgesetzt wurde, abgesägt, die ganze Scheiße?
Es gibt ja so einen Bundesfreiwilligendienst,
vielleicht gibt es ja ähnliches.
BfD?
Alles hat immer Abkürzungen.
Bufdi. Statt Civi Bufdi.
Kann man schlecht, schwer ernst nehmen. Apropos schwer ernst nehmen, das war die Folge für diese Woche. Wir wünschen euch eine ganz fantastische Woche. Bis nächste Woche. Ja, kauft mal ein Müller-Mefoll-Bart. Genau, tut das und wirklich, falls ihr... Das war eine Folge, wo man praktisch was mitnehmen können. Total, absolut. Lektionen fürs Leben.
Und falls ihr mit einem übergewichtigen Erzieher in einem Ferienlager wart, mit dem ihr Heissluftballons... Schickt uns eine saftige Sprachnachricht.
Schickt uns eine saftige Sprachnachricht, wo ihr richtig tief einatmet am Anfang.
So, hi, wie geht's dir?
Haut rein, macht's gut.
BMA, macht's gut, ciao.
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr Hi, wie auch wir, Stefan. Haut rein, macht's gut. Haut rein, macht's gut, BMA. BMA, macht's gut, ciao.
Hätten wir nicht vorher die Luftfahrt anrufen sollen, dass wir abheben? Wir hätten sie vorher abfragen sollen.